welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina and this is fitness origins a
fitness competition show where i use the
films of the mcu
to inspire my fellow nerds on their way
to becoming superheroes and guess what
it's phase two baby
eric and tommy have been working out and
eating right consistently for four
freaking weeks i am genuinely so proud
of these guys for making it this far
but here's the thing if you're getting
comfortable it's time to push yourself
even harder and these are the two
comfiest boys i've ever seen in my life
so
it's time to strong-arm them into
pushing themselves
way harder
eric always good to see you and welcome
to my good friend tommy
who the hell is tommy either you're
having a severe brain issue
or you know that the theme of the week
is captain america winter soldier
why not both well yeah do we need to
call someone are you okay
no no not at all are you throwing
shields at us this week because i've
been practicing my frisbee catches
philip i hate to sound like a broken
record but i think i'm good i think this
goose is cooked
pack it in boys we're done for this
challenge what a great ride
[Music]
yes you you've been doing good but phase
two
means you're gonna have to step it up a
notch that means in the workout videos
that you're using you need to listen to
the parts where the handsome host of
those suggest that you add on a set or
you go a little longer you push a little
harder but also
like you guys learned last week even
just picking up the tempo
or shifting out of using a modification
that can get your heart rate
way up by itself yeah like it's ready to
leap out of your chest but then it says
no i'm not cap i don't jump out of
planes without parachutes
[Laughter]
all right guys uh i do have a twist oh
boy
for this first week of phase two since
this is all about adding something to
your difficulty level
i also want to say it can just come from
adding
another active session in some way
so that's what i want you guys to do
this week in the winter soldier
captain america and future falcon sam
wilson
they lean into some competitive jogging
though it is friendly they don't go
after each other too hard because cap
would probably kill falco if he did
but also that's because the point isn't
really to beat the person it's to use
their example and their effort level to
motivate yourself
to keep going and keep pushing so the
theme of the week
is captain america the winter soldier
but you're having me and tommy be
cap and sam wilson not cap and
god bucky it eric here to bring it up
okay look i've really tried
i really really tried but our insurance
company kept saying no
first i wanted to run a helicopter i've
been longing for way to get that bulging
muscle cap moment
so bad but immediately no go then i
wanted to have tommy stand in front of a
car that is
slightly inching forward and have eric
try to hold on to the rusted bumper and
keep you alive but we couldn't agree how
much value to assign to tommy's life
with the insurance company apparently 17
000 is not enough
i tried dumping you onto a frozen tundra
with no instructions on how to get back
into town and you would have until
daybreak or until your internal furnace
gave out until we released a pack of
nine dogs to bring you in
the most freaking benign idea was just
having you guys throw metal discs at
each other outside your home coming up
with sick ass frisbee moves
but basically this one insurance agent
has been
watching this show and it seems like
this is the one person that not only
does not think you guys are gonna
succeed
they don't think you're gonna survive
the show so we're just doing jogging i
want you to push each other
until you can hopefully by the end of
the week successfully jog
one mile without stopping success
without stopping what is it
a mile yeah that's like a thousand miles
no of what it's yeah it's 5 000
you guys can do this i believe in you
you've done so much already can we
ride in a car for half of it maybe a
freight car
ready to comply great all right well
have a good week guys hold on hold on
did you program us
i liked it week five day one challenge
which to my surprise was just
more of the same but you know what would
help here is a
partner i've got eric boss here we're
gonna go jogging
are you coming are you on my left are
you passing
no no tommy daddy
after you do a lot of these you start to
really feel that burn in your arms and
your lower back
and your core feeling good hello
[Music]
no way no way tommy whatever
so this was the day i was most afraid of
for this week
now that we're going into week five
everything gets way harder than the week
before
so with this one i had to take short
rests in between of all these hit
exercises
it's ironic that this week we're
focusing on captain america the winter
soldier
and guardians of the galaxy which are my
two favorite marvel movies
yet this week has been my least favorite
week of doing these exercises
since the first week you're a little
overconfident started running and my
legs immediately seized up like they
were forced gump's legs in the movie
i blame the mountain climbers yeah the
mountain climbers really got to me
i'll say this though yeah tomorrow's the
big day so we're gonna get it tomorrow
tomorrow we're gonna get the mile
tomorrow belongs to us all in one
sitting okay i feel myself getting a
little bit stronger
uh more capable of running that mile
with my co-pilot
yeah all right on your right on your
left
we're doing it here is the mile
we got the miles
dunkin donuts around the corner yeah
let's do it let's do it cheat day early
hey look at my little triathletes a week
of running and you guys saw the hardest
part of jogging is actually
telling your mind to just chill the [ __ ]
out you give yourself a tangible goal
and you surprise yourself
how do you guys feel uh tired but hey
you know what
the hardest part was just learning to
love tommy
i that came out mean that came out mean
it's so easy to love tommy
i had to remind myself to stop being
such a competitive jerk and just
love the easy to love fella who's at
your side
on my left and i reiterate loving eric
also made me hard
yeah no adding that extra cardio in was
uh invigorating philip you know i
doubted you i said what does this guy
know he's not in shape you know i said
let's give him a try even a blind
squirrel gets a nut every now and then
and i think there's something to this
cardio thing i wonder if skipping cardio
for 36 years was a mistake
i'll actually say now that you're on the
other side of it the
adding something has nothing to do with
it has to be running or anything and
also
you can get it just from pushing
yourself harder in your 15 minute
workouts you already have i'm just
trying to show you guys that there's a
lot of ways to
get these calories burned get some
minutes and also i really appreciate
how much you guys are willing to deal
with all the chafing honestly it's just
nice to feel something down there
guys now that we are in phase two uh by
the way uh
i just wanna give a huge shout out to
doordash
you guys watching this know it is no
secret
that we would never be able to make such
a ridiculous show as this
without some help obviously that help
came in the form of doordash every
single week
they let us do all sorts of goofy stuff
and let tommy say all sorts of crazy
things
flexibility is my specialty and they're
willing to put their name on it
and really i'm just grateful that i got
to have some fun
and also my friends get to be silly and
get healthy all as part of their day
jobs it's a pretty cool deal
it means a lot when you use that
doordash code we're all ordering food
like crazy
some of it's healthy some of it's not
but doordash does not limit your options
you can do groceries on there you can do
whatever you want you order through the
app so
please download the app choose what you
want with a minimum order of 15
and our promo code nerdfitness you get
25 freaking percent off
no delivery fees up to a 10 value let's
thank
them and put food in your belly 25
off discount zero delivery fees on your
first order with the doordash app and
then
code nerd fitness don't forget the code
nerdfitness it's how they know that we
certainly
yeah use that code use our link if
you're going to use doordash just help
us out while you're doing it right
use doordash use our code get yourself a
funnel cake you greedy bastard come on
live it up
speaking of rewarding yourselves what
cheat meals are you looking for this
weekend
phillip it's very simple i knew i was
doing a great job this week
lulling eric into a false sense of
security thinking that we were friends
and it was all part of my plan
to win this cheat meal because i am
dying
for a burger and fries give me a big
burger barely kissed by fire raw
ass burger an asperger bring on
a quarter pound of ass in burger patty
form
and then some fries of any variety thick
cut
thin cut waffle cut curly tater tot
give me an orgy of french fries philip
and then eric i love going to like um
build your own burrito bowl places and
getting a quesarito that's where you get
the the burrito but with like an extra
layer of melted cheese and another
tortilla shell around it
i want that but minus the burrito so
just the shell of a quesarito
uh so really just two tortillas
flattened with like meat and cheese that
you can you know dip in sour cream or
guacamole or
something like that just like a flat
tortilla like really fold it it's just a
quesadilla
no no quesorito minus a burrito i'm not
gonna go
wrap a burrito and then unwrap it and
turn it into a quesadilla you know who
would do that for me is
my man tommy would do that for me i
would do that any day for you eric i'd
die for you
well no hey i'm not asking that that's a
week week 13 thing
i have to be able to order it so i'm
gonna call it a quesadilla sure whatever
well we'll see who wins but in the
meantime guys
i'm impressed this time it seems like
you're actually wearing your finished
attire it's friday
let's get limber all right let's get up
this whole thing
so it's the end of guardians of the
galaxy vol 1. star-lord is facing off
against ronan the accuser for control of
the power stone
and how does he defeat him the power of
friendship you two
are gonna hug and kiss for as long as
i'm kidding it's dance he beats him with
dance it's a guardian's a galaxy
dance-off you knew it would be except
i'm not gonna ask you to freestyle even
though boss i know you weirdly have some
b-boy dance moves i'm not kidding i saw
him
break dance in college instead i want
you all focusing on controlled movements
that will test
your flexibility and your stamina so i
made up five different dance moves for
each of the five different guardians and
you're gonna watch these scroll across
the screen as the indicated dance move
goes by
repeating it as you see it wait that
sounds like ddr i'm gonna destroy you
old man
oh i'm like two years older i know i
could teach you these dance moves myself
but as you all know i recently suffered
a catastrophic toe injury oh
so i'm gonna tag in an expert come on
over bridgette hey hi bridget
hi bridgette all right bridget let's
show the guys the dance moves we worked
on i'm going to call out the moves and
then
eric and tommy just try to do what
bridget does starting with
star-lord
see i get this one little disco dancing
yeah i can do this
i don't know if all parts of me can do
it together though yeah i don't feel as
fluid as she is
up next gomorrah
[Music]
violence
now let's see drax
[Music]
eric you okay well he just yells it
helped me feel more like drax yeah you
seemed like drax for a second i thought
you were him
oh thanks now rocket raccoon
[Music]
we have to go that low yeah we do
oh yeah and finally of course i am
groot
[Music]
all right
[Music]
all right guys i've got some workout
clothes for you guys to change into
uh and when you get back we'll dance
okay not so
fast i think i got myself a little
possibly you're gonna look so
good in that players ready oh hell yeah
let's go baby three two
one
let's go boss yeah we are through
how do i do both
[Music]
can we do both why is there two at one
time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are groot oh hell yeah
this is just all of the character
[Music]
yeah yeah man that sounds good
i think we killed him
i think we also may have killed the art
of dancing
or we brought it back to life we're
bringing dancy back
yep damn well bridgette
how do you think they did i mean i feel
like they gave it their all
yeah all right bridget who do you think
won
no one great all right thanks so much
bridget thank you
thank you i of course did keep track and
based on points the winner is
erin yeah baby told you're going down
old man
of course that doesn't mean that they
won the week will combine points from
this challenge as well as how they
performed all week long
to decide who's gonna win that sweet
sweet door dash cheat mail
happy sunday boys how did you guys enjoy
your little dance battle
uh i was like zemo out there baby i
could not stop
dancing i learned something about eric
that day
his hips tell no lies his moves are just
like jagger
it probably was still a lot of people's
surprise but not mine because i went to
college with eric i saw him rock that
ddr game every single weekend instead of
recording potential lovers
i mean hey the student union never had a
student who worked that ddr mat the way
i did
so yeah we got the points counted and
eric definitely won the guardians of the
galaxy dance battle
however as you guys know the challenge
is only part of what decides the winner
eric
tommy remind us what you ordered for
your cheat meal um
i got a quesarito minus the burrito so
whatever you want to call that uh
quesadilla got it okay an eric sandwich
is what i call it and what i dream about
i got a big burger burger and fries is
what i ordered all right well that alarm
means that uh you all both have your
doordash drivers waiting for you
so go ahead and get your food and i'll
let the audience know why it is that one
of you is getting your delicious cheat
meal and the other one is getting your
technically
a meal go for it all right okay so
this week the guys both really did push
themselves harder and the running was a
really
interesting way to watch them work
through the desire to just
want to give up on something at the end
of the day though what i really
appreciated the most was the way that
eric was just so supportive of tommy
tommy
so our winner of this entire week is
hey yay i
quesadilla yum yum
i tried to give the notes about put it
in a uh around a burrito and then give
it back and they wouldn't do it but they
give you a quesadilla they did it tell
me what you get
i got a big box of lettuce i think
that's called a salad tommy
no it's a box of trash can i just eat
this all the time now that i'm a fitness
extraordinaire
no you can have it once a week if you
win the challenge
uh each week or after that just as your
cheat meal tell me what so how's your
mouth feel
it feels healthy and i hate it all right
well congratulations to you guys both
all right that's it for this episode of
fitness origins oh and also make sure
please for the love of god use that door
dash code
nerd fitness please as always let's hear
it for the boys in the comments below
i've been philip molina and i'll see you
next time on fitness origins
star-lord star-lord yawn dude
kevin foggy cabin fire
[Music]
dude
[Music]
is